[Music]
yo what what yo I wasn't here for the
earlier the ver what are you talking
about I don't even know I just joined so
why do you think Islam is true I think
Islam is true because it just you know I
believe it's true what else is there you
know what I'm saying I I feel it bro I
feel it you believe Islam is true
because you believe it bro what what
else is it I mean what else we got it
but I believe yeah I know what you say I
feel you bro talk to there multiple Mir
there's multiple miracles in the Quran
that are going on predicted that's been
predicted that are going on right now
like what like what tell us man okay the
Euphrates River driving up you know what
I'm saying that's in the Bible too but
it's in the Bible yeah so that that
don't that shows that the Bible is true
in the Quran we be copying the Bible
okay the what is it called the universe
but just just really quick that that
that proves that the that the Bible's
true right with it having true Miracles
and prophecy like that no that doesn't
prove anything bro but you just brought
it up as a proof for listen listen
listen listen list listen the Quran
doesn't say that everything that Jesus
said was false you know Jesus was a
prophet too so he could have said that
like all right hey man you came up here
you you did your thing bro I got a
question for you though listen I got a
question I don't got no answers bro the
only thing I can tell you bro is that I
believe man I believe what what else
what else we got you
know what else we got man what else we
got I I don't know listen I don't know
why you tweaking out right now no I'm
not even saying anything I'm not even
tweaking out I'm on my belief man you
you on your belief bro and I'm I'm I'm
on my
Bel what else we got man what else we
got you know what I'm
saying what else we got dog you know I'm
talking about hey man hey put it here
man what else we got man what what else
we got do what else we got we just got
our police man you know what I'm talking
about shoot shoot hey thanks for coming
up man thanks for sharing man thank you
I'm I'm end it there man I'mma end it
there I'mma end it there I'm just I'mma
just call it I'mma call it cuz that that
I'mma call it cuz what else we
got what what else we got here
man can you hear me yes I can hear you
uh is it broer is that how they say your
name yeah broer um yes I'm Muslim um so
I'm reading this okay Islam is false all
right change my mind okay speaking of
Change My Mind four wife in this world
72 wh version in heaven I'm sure have
you read the Quran what's uh how Muslim
describe the heaven you're not a Muslim
I am Muslim so the thing is changed my
mind four wife in this world 72 virgin
in heaven how is that sound sounds like
Las Vegas well what I'm saying how do
you guys describe the heaven like in
Muslim heaven is like a river of wine
you know what I'm saying it's not that
I'm making up making fun of that the way
we describe the heaven how do do you
guys describe the Heavenly Bible you're
not a Muslim why not I could tell you
believe Muhammad is a you believe
Muhammad is a true
Prophet who what I'm
sorry what what do you think about what
the past guest said you think he was
making sense I think it was kind of
stupid you're a Muslim right yeah yeah
just making sure did I pay you to come
up here huh did I pay you no no you
didn't okay okay just all all right so
you're not one of my paid actors dang it
okay so you think that the last guy what
he said was pretty stupid all right so
tell me tell me your take on it what's
your take on it bro in the verse it
doesn't say it's fully it says it's
detailed but it doesn't say it's fully
detailed okay so obv wouldn't like um I
don't know how to explain but like it
does say detailed about all things right
yeah in all topics so does does all
things mean fully no it means in like um
in like topics topics wise so it's
detailed about all the topics yeah so is
it detailed about the topic of Adam and
his wife it doesn't say fully detailed
but I guess but you said it's it's
detailed it's it gives all the details
about the topics it talks about right
yeah but not fully about many things but
you fully means all doesn't it yeah in
in like detail wise I don't know how to
explain this the only way to explain it
bro is to say yes it's detailed about
everything and you want to know the way
out of this the way out of this is
saying yes logic it's a contradiction
man I renounce Islam that's the the way
out of this okay in in the okay it's
it's detailed but not fully detailed but
it's detailed in every topic okay so it
doesn't have a deep explanation about
all things it just has a little bit of
detail it has only a little bit of
detail even though it says it's detailed
about all things right yes it still has
detail though right it has details but
not details about all things right the
depend yeah okay so but that's the
problem it has details but not about all
things but the Quran says that it has
details about all things so that's a
contradiction wait yeah I don't I I
don't know how to explain this in my
head there is there is no explanation
there is no explaining this brother I'm
trying to help you the only way to
explain this is to is to say yes it's a
contradiction the book is false that's
it the thing is it doesn't it doesn't
say fully okay it has detail in all
things but not fully but it still has
details all right sounds good Minor
Detail okay okay okay all right thanks
thanks for thanks for for sharing that I
appreciate you bro okay could you like
explain to me why you think Islam is
false I believe Islam is false because I
don't believe that prophets can be
Bewitched I don't believe that demonic
or dark powers or of evil powers can
control them Muhammad being Bewitched
cancels them out as a prophet but what
do you mean by he was Bewitched like in
what way that magic was worked on him
and his mind was being controlled to the
point where he did not know what he was
doing or saying for a very long time
okay but Muhammad he was a person he was
a human right yeah prophets can't
prophets can't be Bewitched they have
this they have they have the spirit of
God humans as well prophets were humans
but they had a special connection with
God correct they cannot be Bewitched
they have the spirit of God the thing is
they were humans they're not like super
people with like supernatural abilities
they have the spirit of God they cannot
be Beed they may okay but they were
humans and humans can come across
Temptation and everything temptation is
Temptation is not being Bewitched okay
but in my in the sense I'm talking about
humans come across everything in life
can do they not yeah bewitchment is not
a process of Temptation or trials that
you go through as a Believer as a pro as
a prophet you cannot be Bewitched or
overtaken by demonic Powers but life is
a test you can come across anything I I
feel like you're ignoring what I'm
saying are you hearing what I'm saying I
can I okay so I said that the prophets
have the spirit of God so evil spirits
cannot overcome the spirit of God that
are that is within the prophets or that
is upon the prophets okay let's go back
where did you hear that he was bited and
the Hadi which one let me pull it up for
you all right sah bukari 3175 can you
read it out for me yes it says narrated
Aisha um once the prophet was beitch so
that he began to imagine that he had
done a thing which in fact he had not
done okay so basically a dream no
hallucinations hallucinations or
whatever it is this the the the evil
Powers worked on him to where he thought
he was doing things that he wasn't even
doing wa what yeah he was Bewitched to
the point where his his mind he he
didn't have control of his own mind he
Bewitched so that's the reason why you
think Islam is false it's one of reasons
it shows that Muhammad's a false prophet
because prophets can other reasons
prophets can't be Bewitched okay what
other reasons are there wait what do you
have to say about this one no I'm just
saying what other reasons are there and
I I I'll get to that I'll show you the
other reasons but this is this is
top-notch you don't what do you what do
you think about that you you believe
that a prophet can of God who has the
protection and spirit of God on them do
you think that that that they can be
Bewitched I
do the Quran doesn't even the Quran goes
against that look let me show you if you
go to chapter 16 let's go to like
98 so chapter 16 was starting at verse
98 um when you're paused I can't hear
you just to let you know oh my butt
sorry sorry it's all good but I'm gonna
read it out if you want to look at it
yourself as well you can but this
chapter 16 ver 98 it says so when you
want to recite the Quran seek Refuge
with Allah from shaan from shaan the
outcast verse 999 yeah verily he has no
power over those who believe and put
their trust only in their lord right so
Satan has no power his power doesn't
work on those who believe and trust
Allah okay but but okay but there was
another Prophet was well Prophet I don't
know his name in English let let me
finish this let me finish this okay okay
okay so it's verse 100 it says his power
so Satan's power is only over those who
obey him and follow him and who uh join
partners with Allah so Satan's Powers
doesn't work against those who believe
in Allah and Trust in Allah they only
work against those who follow Satan and
commit sh so if the powers of Satan was
working against Muhammad that means
understand I understand what you're
saying but there was another Prophet as
well Prophet a I don't know his name in
English but there was he was a True
Believer of God he had everything God
gave him everything um what do you call
it the devil became jealous of him and
then God gave him permission like the
devil to take everything away from the
prophet that was basically the devil's
KN oh sorry the devil's doing not God so
he basically wait what did you just
receive a message confusing myself I'm
confusing myself sorry I'm sorry I'm
confusing myself
but wait wait wait sorry I forgot what I
was saying you're talking about the
story of Job who had troubles from Satan
yeah him yeah yeah that's not bewitch so
you know what I'm saying basically yeah
yeah I know I know what you're saying
and you're not saying you're not you're
not dealing with what what I'm bringing
you're
some someone in the chat said you're
being
Bewitched that was that was good that
was the the moment like was was crazy
right it was pretty good timing good
timing joke good timing joke but look
trials and tribulations
hardships is is not the same as is being
Bewitched having evil power controlling
your mind and affecting
you she
left uh can you explain the Trinity
please Avery no it doesn't make logical
sense does it it's a contradiction right
it makes logical sense there's no
contradiction in the Trinity I don't
have to explain it to you how can how
can the Son of God be the same God Islam
Islam is false change my mind that's
what it says here the point is if
there's a logical contradiction your
understanding of God then Therefore your
understanding is not correct in Islam
okay so if my understanding is incorrect
of God that makes Islam true it's the
only other reliable source but how how
does that work it's a one of the only
major religions it's either Christianity
Islam or Judaism so how come Judaism
wouldn't be true if Christianity is
false because Judaism is a is earliest
Revelation so is Judaism true Judaism is
true yes in part in part yes what do you
mean what do you mean in part it's
either true or it's not okay well no my
my point is that it it doesn't matter
it's it's God logic it doesn't matter
bro just explain it just explain the
trity how can it make logical sense why
do I have to explain the Trinity to you
if Christianity is false I need other
options Judaism seems to be a good
option for me so why not why can't why
why not just lean towards Judaism
because the further Revelation further
Revelation no according to Judaism there
is no further Revelation the Messiah is
it where does it say that it says it in
Daniel 9 it says in Daniel 9 that the
Messiah will bring an end to sin and to
prophecy to Vision so he'll be the last
he'll be the seal he's the Seal of uh
sin of Prophecy and the end of sin Jesus
came after Daniel so what are you
talking about exactly so when the
Messiah came he's the last messenger
he's the last prophet he's the seal
that's what Daniel says he prophesies
the coming of the Messiah right but John
came after Jesus right John came after
Jesus right John yes in Revelations
prophesying John was John was John is a
contemporary of Jesus he didn't come
after Jesus no he he prophesied after
Jesus was already dead he he expounded
on the gospel that was already there he
didn't bring anything new uh he
certainly brought new prophecies in
Revelation no he you're missing it the
the Revelation that John received was of
the Gospel that's what he received so
further revelation of the Gospel um the
coming of the Messiah his mission and
all this stuff that's it's it's
expounded on in the Book of Revelation
in John's Revelation not it's not a new
revelation it's not a new thing a new
message but I I don't want to get into
semantics but it does add new
information about like the end of the
world and stuff so it's yeah but that's
still the GOP it's still the gospel
that's the point it's expounding on the
already set message the already set
Revelation is the goel and you can
logically say that Muhammad is getting
you know expounding on the gospel as
well is he is Muhammad's message the
gospel part of the Gospel no okay then
so you can't say that John John's
Revelation is part of the Gospel is the
point the inil which we do not have a
copy of was the thing that was confirmed
at the time okay no no no I'm leaving
Christianity I'm going with Judaism all
right go ahead go ahead and go with
Judaism but like here here's the thing
you know what here's crazy the most
Jewish thing I could the most Jewish
thing I could do is believe in Jesus
that's crazy isn't it you know obviously
there are Jews for Jews for Christ but
sure yeah so I'm I'm sticking I'm
sticking with Judaism since Christianity
is false I'm going stick with Judaism
and you know fortunately it leads me to
the same beliefs as Christian
Subhan Allah Avery if you can't explain
how the Trinity is not a logical
contradiction how do you expect anyone
to believe in Christianity uh what does
that got to do with Islam being false I
think that that if there's two billion
Christians and they you know don't
believe in the Trinity then they're
going to look at other options and I
think what is that what does that got to
do with Islam being true or false does
the TR does the Trinity does the
falsehood of the Trinity make Islam true
it's one evidence one evidential point
obviously how is that an evid how is
that an Evidence
to Islam because it confirms the Islamic
Viewpoint that the Trinity is not true
but so what about the other viewpoints
out there that the Trinity is not true
like for example Jehovah's Witnesses or
something or Mormons they don't they
also don't say that the Trinity is true
so is the Trinity not being true proving
that Jehovah's Witnesses have the True
Religion yeah I mean it's it's it's
you're right that it's it's one
evidential point and there are other
things to consider you know like you're
look so it doesn't it doesn't make it
doesn't make Islam true can you just
conceed that man and let's get to some
yes I I can see that it's one evidential
point and that you can't just that's not
what I said that's not what I said it's
not an evidential point at all it has no
bearing on whether Islam is true or not
you get it well it's I get what you're
saying yes but my point is one so what
what makes Islam true that's what I
that's the question you know so you okay
you're not going to answer the question
about the logical contradiction that I
assume well the topic it says Islam is
false changed my mind so uh forgive me
your grace if you know I started this
live and I didn't have you in mind your
highness to you know have the topic of
The Logical you know issues of the
Trinity as my topic and please again
forgive me my insolence Your Grace the
topic you know is Islam is false and
again forgive my impotence I do tend to
stick with the topic Your Grace so yeah
fair enough I you know ultimately uh
Islam is false so I think you're right
you know and Jesus is is God so yes I
agree with you so anyway have a nice so
you were trolling me yeah just a little
bit all right have a good one man